Algeria is bracing for once bad protests
as demonstators awake confirmation on wether or not
the country's president abdelaziz boutaflika
will indeed seek a fifth term
crowds turned out in the capital ALGIERS and other towns
calling at the 82 year old and combat to drop his plan to run again
Boutaflika has been
in power since 1999
and he is reportedly in bad health
ralis demanding his resignation began 10 days ago
and they've gained a man tom, I had of sunday's midnight
deadline for contenders to officially register
their condidacy
with me in the studio now for more this is
dw's bachir amroun
an algerian journalist, Bachir thanks so for being here
so as we just mentioned, the deadline
for condidats to register for Algeria's
presidential polls in April
is tonight, do yo think boutaflika
is going to run, again? Well, according to algerian constitution
express the condidats need to go in person to the constitution consul and denounce they will run
and as we know boutaflika is in switzerland in geneva
and he is very unwell and receiving medical treatments, so
the only possibility in my opinion is that
they break the constitution and
announce his condidature
without
requiring him to do it in person
in my opinion, also there are 3 possible
scenarios for today, the first one is
as we talk now that the regime puts
boutaflika in the race and announces his
condidature, today before midnight and that will be
very risky because the protesters
will gain strength and the situation could escalate in the
the coming days
the second scenario is that, it's
a scenario which is unlikely, that the regime
don't put Boutaflika further
as a condidat, as that condidat but that
will require that they have another condidat which
is prepared secretly and they will put him
into the race the next days, and the third
scenario which is very unlikely in my opinion
is that the regime announces
other constitutional consul announces
that boutaflika can not work as a president
because of his
health and in that case, the president of the
consul, of the consitituional consul will take over
the power for the next twelves
half month and he will prepare
other
elections, and that scenario is
well fitting for the regime because they can
win time and prepare their own condidats
another time, well he mentioned Boutaflika is in Geneva
getting medical care, he's 82 years old
I mean we've seen his wheelchair bound
is he even capable
of doing another term?
OF COURSE NOT. well, Boutaflika was not even able
to be sworn in before 5 years as a president
so according to the constitution of Algeria
he is not
president because he didn't make his sworn in so well the constitution
respected in Algeria
he won't be an office now
well if he does not run, i mean you say
it's not likely, but let's say he doesn't run again
What would happen to this protest movement ? well
for big part of protesters i think they will go
they will return to the house because they think
this is the utmost what they can reach
in this situation in Algeria but there would be
a hard corp of protesters
who will think they will request further
Regime change in Algeria and
it will be very crucial how big their number could be
in the next days and of course if there is no bloodshed
alright DW Rachid Amroun we really appreciated all your insights
thank you.